الان الى ابرز التطورات الميدانيه لحرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا تطورات الميدانيه
متلاحقه شهيده الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
في الساعات القليله الماضيه اذ تتواصل
ازمه الامداد الكهربائي في كيف بسبب
الغارات الروسيه الاخيره على مشاهد الطاقه
واضطرار الجهات المختصه لقطع الكهرباء عن
مئات الاف المستهلكين جنوبا في مقاطعه
خرسون يواصلوا الجيش الاوكرانيه الاعلان
عن احراز نتائج ميدانيه اخرها السيطره على
قريه شرق نهر
النيل والساده مواقع الانفصاليين في
دنياصف ما اسفل عن سقوطي ضحايا وفقا
للسلطات الموليه لموسكو وقطعته المجاوره
تعرضت هي ايضا لقذف الاوكرانيا طال عده
مناطق وفقا
لسلطات المقاطعه المواليه لروسيا على
الجانب الاوكراني منه
المواطنين على عدم العوده الى القرى
والبلدات بسبب قصف المدفعيه الروسيه